[Music]
new evidence finds the nation's deadly
opioid epidemic is worsening before a
report from the CDC shows a nearly 30
percent jump in emergency room visits
for opioid overdoses in a 15 month
period the increases were seen among
both men and women and for all age
groups rates went up in every region of
the country in two states Wisconsin and
Delaware the numbers more than doubled
our doctor tara Narula is here good
morning good morning you know we just
heard on October the Trump
administration essentially declaring the
opioid epidemic a public health
emergency
but this CDC report suggests it's only
getting worse we are so far from
beginning to make a dent in tackling
this crisis when you hear these numbers
a hundred and forty thousand overdoses
the 40,000 people who died in 2016 as
you mentioned all ages both genders
every part of this country so for anyone
who thinks that this will not touch them
or someone they love they are wrong in
fact the Surgeon General yesterday very
candidly talked about how his own
brother struggles with addiction so we
need more funding for this we need a
multi-faceted approach that involves
community the medical profession
government law enforcement and
individuals the CDC says that doctors
are prescribing less of these
painkillers so why is this epidemic
continuing it's a complex issue but
public health officials are saying that
what we think is we're seeing a change
in the drug supply that really what we
have now are newer more illicit toxic
more potent drugs like fentanyl and
these newer opioids they can cause a lot
of damage very quickly so we're kind of
in this third wave of the epidemic the
first one involved prescription opioids
the second was heroin and here we are
now seeing these illicit more potent
toxic fentanyl like pain medications so
it may not be that more people are using
but in fact that a single use of a more
deadly drug is what we're seeing does
that mean that it then has to be
targeted like any other illicit drug in
other words it's coming from drug
dealers not from doctors offices exactly
and that's why I said it needs this
multi-faceted approach and we keep
hearing that it really is not as it is
not more effective than less risky drugs
the opioids
when it comes to back pain hip pain or
knee pain ladies that latest study shows
that exactly than what is the point well
I think people need to be aware that if
they're given an option for opioids they
should ask to try non-opioid options
that should be used in the lowest dose
for the least amount of time possible
and that you know according to this
study really was not as effective is it
up to the doctors out Tara not just not
to even offer it as an option well I
think a CDC did change their prescribing
guidelines and so doctors are more aware
now and they are being more conscious
about not prescribing but this effort
has to come not just in the prescribing
end it has to come you know this report
yesterday talked about the ER as being a
really pivotal place for helping as well
they are on the front lines people need
to get educated about this I mean Gail
and I were talking about this morning
and I said you know when I had a baby
they prescribed percocet and my mom said
no take them right it'll be fine with
them remote Rijn that's right I was I
was fine a lot of it is education for
patients for families but you know as I
was saying in terms of the ER I mean
this is a point where people who the ER
can make interventions for people who
have come in with an overdose and send
them to medication assisted treatment
get them a prescription for Ana locks on
the opioid reversal drug there's a lot
more we can do thank you all right dr.
Turner Rula thanks